(dramatic music)
(water splashing)
(whooshing sound)
(dramatic music)
I think it helps everybody listening and watching to know
that you're never beyond the need for help.
You're never beyond the need for advice.
And you're never beyond the need to try some new tools
and learn some new skills
so that you can then accommodate the opportunities
that are in front of you.
(upbeat music)
What's up all you beautiful
earth-dwelling creatures and creators.
Welcome to another incarnation of guru multi-verse
where we wade into sacred waters,
both metaphysical and practical.
My co-host for this exploration is Guru Singh,
a Master of the Kundalini Arts,
Guru Singh is a good friend,
he's a celebrated spiritual teacher,
a third-generation Sikh Yogi, an author,
and accomplished musician,
a father, a grandfather, basically a gift to humanity,
now holding virtual court at Kundalini University.com.
The Guru resides in the house of the RRP today
for a dissertation on defining and discerning
the delicate and detailed differences
that differentiate instinct, impulse, intuition,
and intelligence, the four Is.
So this one is about perspective,
it's about accountability,
the willingness to solicit and receive feedback
and why growth depends on your ability
to truly understand and appreciate
the nuances that distinguish these I words.
This might be one of my favorite Vulcan mind melds today.
So hit that subscribe button,
make sure to stick around to the end.
Once again, guru Singh takes out with a song and that's it.
Let us not waste another moment.
This is me and Guru Singh.
(whooshing sound)
We're back again.
Guru, corona is like a thing, it's happening.
You know, with the beauty of your new studio
and your dedication to doing these shows
with people in-person has, you know,
opened up me to the idea that,
well, I'm gonna have to be down here every few months,
if for no other reason,
then we're gonna be-
To pop in.
Pop in and do an hour.
I know you're Mr. Internet now and virtual
and all of that, and that's fantastic
with Kundalini University,
but there is something about the analog experience.
I know.
You know, I just have a really hard time
doing what I do in a Zoom format.
I can do it, but is it the same?
It really isn't.
It isn't the same.
And one of the things that I've always treasured
about our communication is we watch each other,
you know, we're across a desk or across the table
looking at each other and you and I are a bit of an expert
in body languaging, and we start to form our conversations,
not just in the spoken word, but also in the,
you know, the physical expression and the facial expression.
You don't get that in the two-dimensional Zoom world.
Yeah, it's much more difficult.
It's much more difficult.
Yeah, and I think that is true.
I mean, when I sit down with you,
I have an idea of things I wanna talk about,
but other than that, there's no preparation,
which makes us a lot easier 'cause so the guests,
like I have to put in hours and hours and hours
of prep time to be here.
Well, I will interject as an interruption.
It is because this is not an interview.
This is equal partners in a conversation.
And that to me is the greatest value
that I get from our time together,
is that we're not, there's not a person who's an expert
and a person who is an interviewer.
There is two people who are exploring the world.
I hope so, I think that's right.
But if I start to stutter or look like,
I can't think of anything to say,
then I'm giving you the visual cue to step in and save me.
I'll do.
I gotta go to point guard then and run the game.
What I wanna talk about today,
what I wanna focus on is the difference
between instinct and impulse.
When are we following our intuition?
When can we trust our intuition?
When are we basing our actions on instinct
and when are we acting impulsively?
And I think there's different layers to this on some level,
we kind of understand the difference
between these two things,
but it quickly becomes very subtle and difficult to parse
when you're making a decision,
am I doing this impulsively?
Have I thought this through?
What is my intuition telling me?
And can I trust my intuition?
How reliable is my intuition?
For me, I would use a metaphor.
Think of a movie set and you've got a director
and you've got a script.
What's gonna be formed between the director's ideas,
the actor's skills, and the script
is going to be a combination of talents
and impulses and intuitions and instincts.
And sometimes the whole thing ends up in the shooter,
and they go, "Cut.
"Okay, that didn't work out,
"I thought, I was thinking it was gonna end up,"
and what do they do when they have a mistake?
They do a new take.
And the way in which we can, like anything,
learn to trust our intuition is by learning
how to forgive ourselves
for making really horrendous mistakes.
And we can practice, you know,
with little insights and little intuitive
or instinctual behaviors or impulsive behaviors.
And we can start noting how,
how did we do when we followed
that kind of a trigger, knee-jerk response?
And how was it if I, instead of just going with an impulse,
I just stepped back for a moment,
looked at the whole picture,
tried to take as much in as possible
and then arrived at a conclusion
that I would then bank on,
still maybe make a mistake, but work with it.
So I believe there's tremendous value in impulse,
the where, why, and when is going to be significant.
I believe there is tremendous value in holding impulse,
and again, the where why, and when is going to be important.
I believe there's a significant difference
between instinct and intuition.
And we can dive deeper into that.
But I think there's a place for both.
What is that difference?
Like is instinct more in attunement with impulsivity?
Yes.
Well, to a degree.
Instinct is more of a hereditary circumstance.
Instinct comes out of your DNA, out of your physiology.
It's learned behavior, you know,
the capacity for your body to know.
For example, when you're on a long distance bike ride,
run, swim, there will be instincts that are coming up,
that aren't based on just impulse,
they're based on patterns that you have remembered
over many, many years,
many, many years.
And they may be in some ways, patterns that you've inherited
from your mom and dad and your grandparents and generations.
That's what instincts are.
And instincts are stored in the body chemistry.
The idea that you have this body intelligence
is part of what the instinctual network
is able to employ.
Intuition, on the other hand,
is less of physiology and more of a subtlety base.
You start to build your intuitive skills through,
as I've said, in other ones of our interviews,
through the use of the parasympathetic nervous system.
The nervous system that takes a step back,
the nervous system that takes in more of the information,
the data field that is present in the moment
and then starts to allow the co-relation
or what's rapidly called correlations
between the different data points.
When you're in that state of the parasympathetic,
feta brain, the dream-time brain,
all of a sudden, and you've learned how to get yourself
into that state,
you can start forming intuitive determinations or decisions
that are not based on impulse,
but they may take impulse into account.
And so impulse doesn't control the show,
but impulse gets to contribute to the show.
And instinct doesn't control the show,
but instinct also contributes.
And so then all of a sudden you have impulse contributing,
instinct contributing, body intelligence contributing
and larger pictures contributing.
Then as this sounds like a complexity,
but it can happen ultimately very rapidly,
then you can base a decision on all of this impulses.
Like an instinct to me is like a really successful
business leader, a really successful CEO,
that listens to all of the input
and then comes to a conclusion that is collective
or what is called, in my world, the elevated paradox.
You know, you've got all of the issues
that are competing for space
and then you've got the paradoxical issue
that just sort of arises from that tension and pressure.
The four Is.
Yeah, the four Is.
The instinct, impulse, intuition and intelligence.
Beautiful.
Right?
Yeah.
They overlap a little bit with each other.
I mean, the way that I've always thought about this
is instinct, yes, this is something that's bred into our DNA
as animals that have evolved over millennia.
Impulse is a reflection of our emotional bodies
in the experiences and traumas and stresses that we've had
over the course of our lifetimes.
We have buttons that have been installed,
that when they get pushed, we act impulsively.
There's not a lot of neural activity
in terms of like intelligence that comes into play.
We react without thinking about it.
It's only in the wake of that action
or engaging in that impulse
that we then have to pick up the pieces,
or, you know, figure out how we went wrong here,
impulses are-
Or enjoy form-
Yeah, I mean, I tend to associate it
with a negative connotation,
but obviously we have impulses for a reason.
And, you know, back to that sympathetic nervous system,
like an instinct or an impulse can be a way
of keeping you safe or, you know, avoiding danger
or, you know, reacting to a certain stimulus
that is, you know, basically creating a boundary,
any of these things, right?
Yeah, just think about the impulse
as sometimes the first move,
almost like first responders.
And that instinct might be in getting the injured
to a facility.
Intelligence is in the analysis of what's going on.
And then in the midst of surgery,
some intuition comes in when obstacles are met.
You know, so there's a place for all of that.
You said that it combines, you know, those graphics
where they have the circles intersecting circles.
Venn diagram, yeah.
And what is that?
What is it?
The Venn diagram.
Yes, and that sweet spot where they all
share common space, yeah.
There you go.
Yeah.
But intuition, the way that you characterize it
is a little bit of fairy dust,
a little bit of the unknown that comes into play.
I love it.
A little bit of fairy does.
I think the problem, and one of the reasons
why I wanted to talk about this with you today,
is that we can confuse instinct or impulse with intuition.
And my sense is that there are a lot of people
who are living their lives in a manner
that we described in the last episode that we did,
where we're not so connected to ourselves,
we're living our lives reactively.
We're, you know, going to our job and waking up
and just trying to get by.
And we're inoculating ourselves with media, et cetera.
And there's not a lot of internal reflection.
And there's a dissonance between the higher self
and kind of the operating system
that's carrying this, you know, human machine through life.
And I think short of really engaging in that internal work
of self-understanding this exploration,
but I'd like to think that I'm on
and that I know that you're on
of trying to understand ourselves
and trying to reconcile those past traumas
and make sense of them and become more self-actualized
and whole that we begin to develop a sense of the difference
between intuition and instinct in that we've been,
we begin to be able to trust our intuition.
Like, one of the things that I learned early in sobriety
is that I couldn't trust my intuition
because my intuition had led me astray,
had been kidnapped or co-opted by substances
and thought patterns and behaviors
that had taken me to some dark places.
Like I would think, you know, my instinct was,
oh, do that, or I'm conflating these terms,
but my intuition was, I should do this,
and then I'd end up in some terrible situation, right.
So in early sobriety,
I didn't feel like I could trust my intuition.
And I was told that it would probably be a good idea
to not trust my intuition
until I had kind of done enough of this work
to the point where I could dip my toe back
into that test that, oh, that worked out.
Maybe I can trust it a little bit more,
trust a little bit more, trust a little bit more,
to the point where now I feel very confident
in trusting my intuition,
but that was not something that happened overnight.
Yeah, I think intuition,
you've just framed it beautifully.
What your communication just there brought into me
was intuition is a little bit like a pilot's license.
You know, there's a lot of ground skill
that you have to go through,
reading and, you know, trying things
before you actually end up up in an airplane.
And so intuition is very, very real,
but it needs, the skill set needs to be developed.
And oftentimes you said people mistakenly equate emotion
or impulse or instinct for intuition.
I think that a lot of people on a spiritual path
will be mistaken in the opposite direction.
They'll think that they're intuitively feeling something,
and all they're actually feeling
is just a really strong emotion, you know.
And so they're disguising what would be impulse
by holding an emotional impulse at bay long enough
so it feels like it's qualified to make the decision.
And so, and it's a little bit like, you know,
a person that's just taught themselves
how to golf or tennis, play tennis,
and then they find a teacher and the teacher has to undo
everything that they've been doing.
And so they get worse at playing golf
until they get better.
And I believe that it's the same way
with using the four Is that you can use them successfully,
but if you're learning how to train intuition,
to train your instincts to come in
when you need that instinctual behavior,
to train the impulse to be able to come in when you need it.
I mean, driving a car, you better have some good instincts
and some good impulses because things can fly at you
right and left and you need to be able to respond,
and sometimes, really react.
And then there's times when you can follow
the intelligent pathway into the intuitive realm
and it's successful,
but I certainly wouldn't drive my car on intuition.
No.
You'd look like an idiot on the road.
I feel like this process requires an objective
outside counselor.
Like whether that's a mentor or a spiritual guide
or a teacher or a sponsor,
somebody who can reflect back to you the truth
of the decisions that you're trying to make.
I mean, a perfect example would be somebody
who's in a string of bad relationships
and is all ready to commit to this new guy.
I know he's abusive, but like,
I think this is gonna be different.
My intuition is telling me that this is the one.
It's like, no, that's not a well honed intuition,
that is programming built in
by dent of a terrible relationship with your father
who modeled bad behavior and has crossed the wires
in your brain to put you in this position
where you're attracted to that unhealthy behavior.
Until we untangle that knot and really look at
why you keep ending up in these types of relationships,
you're gonna continue to do it,
and you're gonna delude yourself that you're acting
on your intuition when in truth,
you're acting impulsively based upon trauma and, you know,
emotional circumstances that were beyond your control
at a very early age.
That is profound.
And you said it when you first entered sobriety,
I didn't trust my intuition.
That's appropriate.
There's an appropriate time if a person is sort of fixated
and addicted to bad relation
because of the programming that's scrambled,
I'm just using your words,
that scrambled the internal relational wiring
from a bad father or a bad uncle,
or a bad this, or a bad that,
and then that is the time to not trust your intuition.
That is the time to try to trust and get more in touch
with your intelligence patterns
and maybe even your instinctual patterns,
but have your instinctual patterns
pass through your intelligence before you act on-
Now I'm getting confused.
Too many Is.
Too many Is,
but really what you're looking at
is sometimes you have to be that witness.
Sometimes you have to be that guide or that sponsor.
But you're a very unreliable narrator around life.
Correct.
That's the problem.
And that's the, you can't see that when you're in it.
Right.
But there are times that you can then learn by your mistakes
and in that not seeing it when you're in it,
learning by your mistakes requires the giving forward,
which is forgiving.
The giving forward in order to learn from the lesson
and give you self-forward into the new opportunities,
rather than be cringed by the lesson,
crushed by the lesson
and forced to never learn another lesson in that category
and just be single for your whole life, right,
or whatever else is, you know, the circumstance.
Being able to give yourself forward,
to forward-give yourself, to forgive yourself,
and allow yourself to learn, to make the mistake,
like I said on the movie set, cut,
cut your loss.
But in that context, you have a director
who is the objective outside observer who says, cut,
this is not working.
You're way off track here,
your intuition is leading you astray.
I think we all need some version of that person as a mirror,
as a, you know, a non-interested party
who can reflect back the truth of the decisions
that you're trying to make.
That's interesting that you wanna do that.
Tell me more about why you think that's a good idea.
That is the value of a lot of things.
That's the value of having a sponsor in sobriety.
That's the value of having a therapist in life.
That's the value of having a teacher, a counselor,
that's the value of having that witness and, you know,
in today's world, the idea of a guru,
and by the way, I'm not selling myself here
because my name is Guru Singh,
it's not my position or title,
but the idea of the guru, right,
the teacher, the wise one,
the one who's been through it before.
And however you assimilate that,
whether it's a sponsor, a witness, a friend,
I call it an accountability buddy.
You know, I have an accountability buddy.
I have an accountability buddy in my wife.
I have accountability buddies in my children.
And if I can't pass my behavior through their eyes
and through their senses,
then I'm looking at it as inappropriate
or as I shouldn't go down that pathway.
So filling ourselves with sponsors,
with people who are wiser than we are,
is really a value added.
Yeah, I think it's crucial.
I mean, there's a couple pieces to this
that I think are important for those that are listening
or watching who haven't had the experience
of being in therapy or are not part of a spiritual community
or a 12-step community.
I think we all have people within our communities
or in our circles that are wiser than us
in various categories.
So perhaps a way to look at it is as a board of advisors,
like when I have a relationship problem,
I know this person who's been in a healthy relationship
for 30 years, like that's the person I'm gonna call
to run this problem by,
or when I have a fitness or a running question,
there's a different type of person that I'm going to call.
Not every guru needs to be able
to check all those categories.
And I think just being in the habit
and developing the humility of running your decisions
by these types of people, is a really great practice.
Even if it just affirms the decision
you are already gonna make, it's still a healthy habit.
And more often than not,
you're gonna come up against some resistance.
Well, maybe you didn't think about this, or maybe,
and they're gonna tell you
that maybe you're not making the right decision,
which is uncomfortable.
And maybe you're gonna make that decision, anyway,
but maybe you'll reflect back on that,
which gets to the second piece
that I wanted to talk about,
which is developing the capacity to receive the feedback.
I think that's the real mover here.
It's one thing to have these advisers or gurus in your life.
But if you can't receive what they're telling you
or advising you of,
then you're not getting off first base, right.
So the capacity to receive the feedback
is a function of humility.
Like, can you set aside your ego
or what it is that you are so attached to doing,
and can you hear the objective outside perspective
on why maybe that might not be the best thing for you.
And I think that dynamic works best or optimally
when the person who is delivering the feedback
is able to do it in a nonjudgmental way, right.
Like how can you keep this on an even keel?
The feedback deliver just says plainly,
did you think about this,
maybe you should think about this.
That's interesting that you wanna do that
and then receive it.
Oh, rather than get defensive, which is an impulse,
I think we all have to develop the capacity
to just take it in, to process it and say,
thank you for that, let me think about that.
It doesn't commit you to a certain path,
but to me, that's the process.
And that's the way that I try to make
most of the bigger decisions that I have to make
and it's traumatically improve my life.
You've housed this really beautifully.
What I understand in that,
the way you've described this,
is that if you're feeling a lot of discomfort
in the reception of the advice,
then you can pretty much be guaranteed
that you are too impulsive.
Yeah, and you could take that as,
oh, that's an interesting piece of information
that I'm feeling that resistance, feeling defensive,
that should tell you something.
And if you're wise you will take that signal
and process it and say, okay,
I'm uncomfortable because my impulse
has already got me moving in this direction
of this choice that I'm making.
And now I've asked somebody to give me their advice
on the choice that I'm already committed to, right.
My impulse is already engaged.
And if that is what is occurring often,
then you have to realize that you need to put more energy
into the other three Is,
the intelligence, the instinct and the intuition.
And you need to draw back a little bit on the impulse
because it's causing you to be uncomfortable
under the influence of the advice
or the suggestions that are coming from the witness.
Be it a sponsor, a therapist, however it is.
What I learned from a lot, is the three brains,
the head brain, the heart brain and the gut brain,
or embraining as medical science,
multi braining, calls it.
The brain in your heart has to work to serve,
but has to surrender to receive.
So if you sort of take that model and apply it
to how are you gonna receive the advice,
how you're gonna receive the advice of a sponsor,
a therapist, a witness of some form,
you're gonna have to surrender.
And surrender doesn't mean giving up.
Surrender just simply means become inactive for a moment.
It doesn't mean that the momentum is lost,
it doesn't mean that anything is lost.
It doesn't mean that the idea is lost,
but it means stop engaging.
It's like a car.
If you put in the clutch, the engine is still there.
All the horsepower is still there.
The wheels are still there.
The drive column is still,
everything is still there, but it's disengaged for a moment.
And maybe in that disengagement, you will say,
well, I should turn the car to the hard right
because the way I was going
is not gonna have a benevolent outcome
because I've talked to my witnesses,
I've talked to my people
and they're all advising me against this.
Or you may say, I'm good to go.
I'm going to go against all advice,
but I'm going to take full responsibility.
And all of these sort of mimicked sequences, mock sequences,
need to be studied.
How many of the decisions that you made against advice
over the last X amount of time,
you talked about we can do more in a year,
or, no, we can do less in a year, but more than a decade,
how many of the decisions that we've acted upon
against advice have turned out?
Is it greater than 50% or less than 50%?
And start coming up with some conclusions
based on real data.
Another way to parse this or look at it,
again, I always go back to the addiction recovery,
I've lens on these things.
It's a beautiful.
One of the things that I've learned is evaluating
these decisions or these impulses or these intuitions
through a calculus of what hole am I trying to fill.
So if I have this notion that pops into my head,
I am feeling very hungry.
I'm protein starved, I must go to McDonald's.
McDonald's is the solution to my problem.
That is my instinct,
that is my gut, it's telling me
that's how I'm gonna solve this hunger that I have.
Well, let's deconstruct that a little bit.
Are you truly protein deficient?
What's driving this hunger?
And what is the emotional discomfort
that you're feeling right now
that your unconscious mind is telling you
will be resolved by putting a gigantic amount of calories
into your gut as quickly as possible?
That will essentially sedate you.
It's an addictive response to an emotional discomfort
that's driving that decision.
Thus, it is less intuition and it is more impulse,
an impulse driven by an unconscious emotional need.
Well, you said the word sedation,
because the unconscious emotional need will remain
once that food is digested and wears off.
Well, you will be sedated for a moment.
You will be sedated so that you won't experience the need.
And then your emotional dis-ease will return.
Exactly.
And what is a more appropriate view in that moment
is to go, okay, my impulse is this.
And by asking yourself, what hole am I trying to fill,
it's got many layers, doesn't it?
And there's many different aspects to the hole
that is being filled here.
And maybe if we just withheld some of the consumption
and spend a little more time in the evaluation,
we might realize something that could be reapplied
over and over and over again successfully
that ultimately ends up changing
the fact that that even comes up.
That we may never have to ultimately
face that same challenge, that same emotional need,
that same hole that needs to be filled.
Yeah.
If you're constantly reaching out to fill the hole
and doing it impulsively
without any kind of higher cognizance of what's going on,
you're just gonna perpetuate that behavior.
But if you take a moment and say,
I'll go to McDonald's in 20 minutes,
but I'm going to sit with this emotional discomfort
and try to figure out why I'm feeling
the way that I'm feeling right now.
More often than not, that will lead to some epiphany.
Oh, I just had a fight with my spouse 20 minutes ago.
That's why I feel uneasy right now.
And I'm reaching out for this thing that I know will fix me,
at least in the short-term.
I think the ego comes into play as well.
Like if somebody comes to me and they say,
I wanna run a marathon, like I've been on the couch,
and I don't like how I feel,
like this is what I'm gonna do.
Like help me figure out how to get there.
And I've told this, some version of this story before,
so forgive me if you've heard it.
But my question to that person,
my first question to that person is always why?
Like, what is the problem that you think
this is going to solve?
I just wanna do it.
I've never done anything.
Maybe that's great,
or maybe you're emotionally out of balance
and you're gonna take on a very difficult goal
only to discover that it wasn't the right goal for you,
because you're not integrated enough
to trust what you think is an intuition
but it's really just an impulse being driven
by some discomfort that you're experiencing.
Sedation periods are very telling,
running a marathon, for example,
you know, requires a lot of preparation,
requires a lot of effort and then there's a recovery time.
And so one of the things
about the sedation of anything,
whether it's a positive or a negative,
is that what you were saying before,
after the fact, the hole remains,
unless the hole itself has been discovered
as to what's causing the hole.
And what you said a moment ago
about going back in time,
you know, let's take 20 minutes, you know,
not go out and grab the burger,
and let's go back in time and see,
okay, what's led to this sensation.
If you do that often enough,
one will find through that discipline
that the sensations are in themselves, very complex.
And a lot of the feelings that we feel aren't our feelings.
A lot of the feelings that we,
'cause we consume through every orifice in our body,
not just, you know, not just putting it into our mouth.
We consume through our eyes and our ears and our nose
and everything.
And a lot of times what is creating the hole
is the fact that we are being targeted by so many people,
in the marketing world, in the sales world,
in the industrial world, in the financial world,
and the political world, et cetera, et cetera,
all of these worlds that are competing for our attention.
On steroids now with the internet,
that there is actually no hole.
There is actually a sensation that there is a hole,
but if I actually get down to it,
I'm good and I don't have a hole.
But if I had sedated the idea that I had a hole,
I could never have been awake enough
to recognize the fact that I don't have a hole,
and that I am being inundated by those things
that can only sell me a fix the whole solution
if I believe that I have a hole.
Right, the idea that you are in lack,
and I have the solution for that lack
in the form of product X, Y, or Z,
or even healthy pursuit A, B or C,
'cause all of those things can be inoculance
that are driven by a sense that you are not complete
exactly the way that you are.
That word, inoculance, I'm gonna steal that, man.
I'm just gonna use it.
I didn't invent it, so go for it.
I know you didn't invent it,
but you really use it with me.
The bottom line with me is that it even applies
to the world that I live in, right.
The world of spiritual teaching and of healthy living,
and of all those things.
Sometimes if a person can just go down inside themselves,
learn a technique to go down inside themselves
and evaluate themselves,
they'll find out that in fact, they're okay
the way they are, it's just all of this other paraphernalia.
And so it might be more of a reductionairy practice
rather than an additive practice.
Let's add this to my life, let's add this to my life.
Or maybe it's let me subtract this from my life.
Let me subtract this from my life.
And if I do that, not to a place of renunciation,
but to a place of, at least I can see and be more clear,
that becomes a place where I can feel
I don't have a hole.
I am whole, I am complete.
It's hard though, man.
It's so much more fun to add stuff.
Subtracting stuff is painful.
Of course, more meaningful ultimately.
But the extent to which this game is rigged against us,
I mean the lengths that we will go, myself included,
to avoid just having to sit quietly with ourselves
is insane.
(whooshing sound)
We'll be back in a sec,
but first, if you dig this podcast,
and I hope you dig this podcast,
then I think you'll really enjoy
my latest book "Voicing Change,"
featuring excerpts from poignant essays
by and glorious photography of some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight plus years of doing this thing,
this podcast.
It's a gorgeous artful, compendium of the show
and copious wisdom shared there in,
all wrapped in a hardcover, coffee table form
that provides a great taste of what we do here
at the RRP and serves as a beautiful keepsake or gift
for the ardent fan.
The book is only and exclusively available on our website.
Signed copies are available and we are shipping globally
direct to any coffee table on planet earth.
So to learn more and snag your copy today,
visit richroll.com/vc.
That's rich roll.com/vc.
All right, let's get back into it.
(whooshing sound)
Well, I remember you and I once having a conversation
around the weighted blanket, and all-
I still sleep with it every night-
And all the relationship is with that weighted blanket
is to literally force you to not move.
To sequester the impulse while you're unconscious.
And it holds you in place.
You know, the weighted blanket
is very much like in biblical terms, the swaddling clothes,
and in native indigenous terms, the papoose,
whereby the child was held in contained and really found
that the flailing of the arms and legs
or the movement at nighttime
was what was causing the sensation of I need to move more,
because that movement didn't give me everything I need.
And so I love it because that weighted blanket
changed your world
and that weighted blanket is a forest stillness.
I'm just a baby that needs to be swaddled.
(laughs) I love it.
Yeah, it's this calming-
And that is your innocence too.
Your sympathetic nervous system,
it's a feeling that it creates this feeling
of safety, right.
Like you're okay, you can relax.
You can let your guard down.
You don't need to be in fight or flight,
all is well with the world.
You are complete, go to sleep now.
We were talking impulse, intuition,
instinct and intelligence.
You know, impulse is a little bit like
the old biblical terminology where such and such begets
such and such more, right.
Using the word begets, right.
An impulse or movement or knee-jerk reaction
contend to inflate the circumstance
and not always, but when it does inflate the circumstance
and then you have to move and become even more impulsive,
and then you have to move and become even more impulsive.
And so that's when I'm just saying that sometimes
like with a weighted blanket,
if you subtract an impulsive move,
rather than enact an impulsive move,
and just give yourself a little bit of time
to open the brain's aperture,
you know, we're on camera right now,
you know, opening up the aperture
of that camera's gonna feed more light into it,
it's gonna give more information into it.
When we can open up the aperture of our own mind
and bring in more information,
maybe that additional information
is the circumstances which can avoid
what are often called the unintended consequence.
Yeah, that goes back to being receptive
to that type of feedback.
When I reflect back on the history of the decisions
that I've made before getting sober,
and then throughout my sobriety,
it's very revealing.
Like I realize only in retrospect
that most of the decisions that I made
when I was drinking and using, were purely impulsive,
driven by the idea that I had a hole,
or just a sense of overall discomfort with myself
that must be quelled.
And I found substance as a means of accomplishing that.
It worked until it stopped working,
but in tandem with that was a drive
to just be a pleasure seeker,
to never be in that discomfort,
to never look at it,
to never try to deconstruct it or understand it
or work through it.
Just make it go away as quickly as possible
for as long as possible.
Then you get sober, you have this explosion of emotions
that are very confusing and disorienting.
And with that, I developed the reflex
to run my decisions by other people,
peers within that community sponsor, et cetera.
And more often than not, irrespective of the feedback,
I would still make the impulsive decision.
So I had to do that for a period of time
and did exactly what you said,
which is tally and inventory of how that worked out.
My sponsor would say, okay, you're gonna do
what you're going to do.
Here's what I, you know,
I'm not attached to whatever you do,
but here's what I think.
Make the wrong decision, suffer the circumstances of that,
reflect upon it, do it again, do it again,
do it again, do it again,
until my actions started to align with the feedback
that I was getting.
And I started to notice that my impulses
were becoming more intuitive and the decisions
that I was exploring were more consistently aligned
with the feedback that I was getting
instead of getting feedback that made me defensive
because this person was telling me I shouldn't do the thing
that I wanna do or kind of already had decided
that I was going to do,
the feedback was saying,
yeah, I think that's a good decision or go for that.
Then I reached a sort of Rubicon with the whole thing
where I wanted to explore myself as an athlete.
It's like, I think I want to do this ultra man race.
I mean, for an addict or an alcoholic to be like,
I've never done an Iron man,
but I'm going to go do this double Iron man.
Any sponsor's gonna tell you,
like, that's probably not a good idea,
or I think maybe you're out of alignment
or perhaps you should, you know,
reflect on that a little bit more.
But that was a situation in which I felt confident
and comfortable in my intuition,
even though it didn't match up with the feedback
that I was getting, because I'd done 10 plus years of work
to get to that point.
And I didn't have any guilt in making the decision
to pursue that, even though it wasn't in alignment
with the feedback that I was getting.
How'd that work out?
At the point where it changed my life and it was great.
And, you know, so, but the important piece
in that whole thing is all the work
that went into getting to that place
where I could then go my own way and feel confident
and comfortable that my intuition was guiding me
rather than handicapping me.
Oh, man.
I love that experience that you just took me through
because let's apply it to the world of having advisors,
having a guru, having a teacher, having a therapist,
having this, having that.
It can't be a forever kind of event
as a only source of your wellbeing.
There has to come a place where you are self-reliant
and it doesn't mean that you throw away the advisors
and just go it on your own.
But it means that you are able to create a segue
between the advice and what you believe
is your own buddying intuition
that you are starting to become wiser,
more intelligent, less impulsive.
And if you can build that trust over time,
by going your way, making mistake, forgiving yourself,
picking yourself back up,
acknowledging that you could use a little more advice
before you go out and do it your own way again,
and then when you do finally get to that place
where you can begin to trust your own intuitive,
your own inner sense, that's what gives you the strength.
And that is what the idea of a teacher, a guru, a therapist,
a sponsor, a witness, anything, is all about.
People in the world of therapy,
people in the world of spirituality,
people in the world of any number of things,
will sometimes get locked into a, you know,
a one perspective is what I always go to.
I always go to this person.
I always go to this, for this person knows best for me.
And like you said previously,
you would go to somebody different for marriage counseling
than you might for running counseling,
as to what's the best way to go forward.
And that's the same kind of trap that we can get,
we can get addicted to our advisor.
Well, also there's an identity
that gets baked into that as well.
This is who I am, I'm a person who follows this person,
or I'm an adoptee of certain, you know, this of philosophy X
or spiritual vein Y.
Or I am, or I can only make my decisions
if my therapist/ my sponsor/ my this, agree with me.
And that provides, if we can use the metaphor,
a muscular atrophy in that self-reliance.
The student must leave the nest at some point.
Exactly.
And so in these worlds of advisory
and in these worlds of building the intuitive muscle
and building in reducing the impulsive nature
and balancing it out with the other three Is,
this world has to become a world ultimately of self-reliance
that is still willing to be a student,
still willing to receive that incredible,
hey, I think about that about you.
I know you've been doing this for a lot of time,
but on this looking from a different angle
and I'm not seeing it.
A great litmus test for trying to understand
whether you're being driven by impulse or intuition
is the 24-hour rule.
If you have a decision to make,
if you need to send somebody an email,
that's perhaps incendiary, sit on it for 24 hours
and see if you feel the same way the following day
or 48 hours or 72 hours.
(indistinct)
If 48 hours later you realize like, yeah,
I probably shouldn't send that email to that guy,
even though I felt so strongly about it the day before,
then you can be assured that that was an impulsive response
to some stimuli versus 48 hours later, you're like,
I still think this is a good idea.
Can I wait another day?
Well, I kind of, maybe I can, maybe I can't,
if you can, like the longer you can push it off
and still feel confident that that's in your best interest,
then you're tipping more into the intuition area.
You just hit the magic number,
which is actually physiologically
and neurologically 72 hours,
perspective changes every 72 hours.
Obviously you have multiple perspectives
going on all at once.
So it's not like every 72 hours,
you're a different framework,
but you're working with a particular perspective
when you wanna send that email.
This is what you want to achieve with the email.
This is what you wanna say in the email,
this is why you wanna say it
because this is what this person did from a perspective.
72 hours, three days, if you can wait,
'cause you said 48 hours, and then you said,
can you wait another day?
24 plus 48, 72 hours in three days, that's a magic number.
And that's not like, that's not like philosophy.
That's like actual physiology.
What I experienced, I'm sure this is very common,
like, I'll get an email that will throw me off kilter.
And I'm so uncomfortable.
I feel like I have to respond to it immediately.
Or you're not real.
I just can't move forward with anything in my,
anything else in my life until I deal with this thing.
Yes, yes, yes.
Every fiber of my being is like, respond now,
respond now, respond now.
And that's feeling like really fierce intuition.
Yeah, and the higher version of myself is like,
step away from the computer, you know.
And it takes everything to do that.
Yeah, yeah.
I love this because this is when we mistake impulse
for intuition, you know.
There is the, you can't let anyone get away with that.
Trigger, if I wait 72 hours, I'm a weakling
because I've let somebody walk on me.
Actually, you've let someone trigger
the actual thing that's gonna walk on you,
which is the result of your impulse.
That's what's going to ultimately walk on you.
However, if waiting 72 hours
and your perspective is still locked in,
then most likely what you're experiencing
is your intuition, go for it.
But I would recon to say that if you kept a tabulation
of how many times you waited 72 hours
and the result was effective,
and how many times you didn't wait 72 hours
or even 24 hours,
and the effect was inappropriate,
that you would find out that it's way more weighted
towards the step away from the computer.
Oh, I mean, you know, 100% of the time.
72 hours later, you're like, yeah, I don't need this.
I'm so glad I didn't send that.
Or I don't feel like I need to do anything.
Why should I give that person so much power?
You know, and also intuition has this ability
of seeing beyond time.
And if I wait 72 hours on a reaction
to make it more of a response,
having an ability to respond,
becoming more responsible, you know,
then what I oftentimes experience is what caused that person
to send me that email in the first place?
And that it wasn't even me,
that in that 72 hours, I will have learned
a lot more about the circumstance,
and sometimes within that 72 hours,
they'll come back to me and say,
you know, I really want you to disregard
what I said the other day, because I was feeling this
because of this, this, this, and this,
and it really had nothing to do with you,
but you were the tallest tree in the forest.
And so my wind hits you.
And those are the rewards that are so incredible
when you do wait and step away from the reaction.
How different would the world look
if Twitter had a 72-hour delay on every tweet.
That you posted and it doesn't post
and you can withdraw it.
And within that 72 hours, you can withdraw,
you can withdraw it.
I mean, obviously like it's supposed
to be a real time news platform
as much as anything else,
it's not functional if that would never happen.
But I feel like if it was an option,
like if you could install, oh, cool,
you know, a preference where every time I tweet or respond,
maybe just when you're responding to other people's tweets-
Can wait 72.
Yeah, maybe we'd alleviate a lot of the pain
that we're causing each other on these platforms.
Yeah, a lot of the mudslinging, stone-throwing.
Because that is the ultimate impulse provocateur.
You read something,
I have to tell that person they're wrong
or some emotional overwhelm occurs
where I must be heard on this thing now.
Just to, as an example,
I established, I don't respond, I don't react
because on social media, no matter how your intentions are,
somebody will find issue with something that you're doing.
Who do you think you're talking to.
I did this like all day long.
Yeah, and so I appreciate that.
And so I just created an inner attitude
that I am not going to bite the bait.
Somebody once told me I'm a Pisces, right?
Pisces is the two fish.
And some wise Vedic astrology ones told me
that the Pisces will die by the bait and the hook.
And so I took that to heart and determined
that I wasn't gonna bite the bait.
I was gonna wait and see if that was really food
or if that was a hook that was trying to entangle me.
And that one decision that I made,
and the fact that I'm able to discipline myself
and follow that decision,
has made a big difference in my life on social media.
I'm not there yet.
Oh yeah, you are.
No, no, no, I mean, I-
You have far more, you have far more bait
hanging out there.
But I mean, I battle with the tension
between being a broadcaster on these platforms
and being somebody who wants to be engaged
in the communities that are coalescing
around this work that I'm doing.
And I wanna be present and I wanna make myself available
to constructive criticism and feedback,
but there's also a dopamine inducing,
you know, addictive piece to this where it's like,
I have to see these comments and then I'm exposed
to all kinds of negativity.
And then I find it very difficult to emerge
out of the haze of all of that.
Like, I don't know that it's doing anything positive
and perhaps all would be better
if I just took a step back
and used it simply like you do,
to broadcast and find other ways of cultivating community
or being engaged with the people who are interested
in what I'm doing here, outside the four walls
of these platforms that have become toxic
for so many reasons.
Well, I would say that there is a moment in the race
in which every cell in your body is screaming at you to quit
and kind of like hitting the wall.
If in responding to negativity,
you have the same discipline that you do that has made you
a successful runner, bicyclist, swimmer,
with everything else that goes on,
you're a vegan triathlete
that if you could use the same deflectors,
Like Aikido that has no offensive move,
but uses the energy that's being thrown at you
to reverse onto itself.
If you develop that skill set,
then you would be a person in demand
even more so than you are because the old saying,
the tallest tree catches the most wind.
And you are, in the industry, you are a tall tree.
In my industry, I am a tall tree,
and we both catch both nourishment through the roots,
and we catch wind at the top.
What I do is I develop a skillset that allows me,
particularly during these times of scandal and pandemic
and all of these things where people
are throwing a lot more stuff at those of us
that are putting ourselves out there than ever before,
but I find that if I look at the opposition
like an Aikido master would,
that that's just energy.
That isn't actually opposing me,
that's going to energize me.
Then I have to figure out, okay, that's a philosophy.
What's the practicality?
How can I actually achieve that?
And therefore I would, the 24-hour rule,
maybe not in social media, you have a 72-hour rule
'cause you may be way behind the curve then,
but at least have a 24-hour rule.
And if nothing else, have a 12-hour rule,
you know, on certain things,
but also have ways in which you can become less personal
because there has to be an opportunity
within your own nervous system
to be able to take the criticism,
which is obviously not personal
because nobody except a few people know you.
So they can't say who you are or what you've done.
And make it less personal,
and it ultimately becomes more of a teaching mechanism,
sets what you're doing all the time.
I mean, you don't have the kind of following that you have
because you're an authority.
You have the following because you love authorities
and you gather authorities together.
And people know that if you wanna know something
about anything, go to the Rich Roll Podcast
and look through it, and you will find,
because he's got an admiration,
and maybe, I don't wanna use the word authority,
he's got admiration for wisdom.
He's got admiration for people who are very intuitive,
who are very intelligent and then you present those things.
And for some of those things,
you get deep, negative feedback.
And in that way you apply the art of Aikido,
which simply means no offensive moves,
it's the Dow of no offensive moves,
and you understand that you presented something,
somebody had a bad experience with it,
but that wasn't about you.
Of the one or 2000 people that had a bad experience with it,
There were 50, 70, 100,000
who had a really good experience from it.
And so the ratio is still super positive.
I'll try to bear that in mind.
You got to, because you're doing such incredible work.
Such a people pleaser,
though have so many insecurities around this
that I fall prey to, you know,
seeking validation in the wrong places,
because I still delude myself into that belief
that there is a hole that must be filled
and chasing the fulfillment of that hole
in all the wrong places.
And I'm just calling myself out as a human being
that when I'm not spiritually fit,
I can find myself doing that.
And it always leads to a not-so-good place.
Well, let us both call ourselves out in this moment,
just so that the audience that is watching or listening
can understand that happens to all of us.
This last year I've had to learn a lot of new tools
to deal with depression.
I've had to learn a lot of new tools to deal with pushback,
really negative pushback.
And so I think it helps everybody listening and watching
to know that you're never beyond the need for help.
You're never beyond the need for advice.
And you're never beyond the need to try some new tools
and learn some new skills
so that you can then accommodate the opportunities
that are in front of you.
Because as they often say, you know,
all the negatives is just the positive
with it's ASEN forward.
And it all begins with a commitment
to hone that intuition.
And to do that, we need teachers, we need advisors,
we need humility, we need curiosity, we need wisdom,
we need gurus and a good place to begin that journey.
And we need forgiveness-
Just might be, forgiveness, compassion, gratitude,
and we can go on forever.
Yeah.
But if you're interested in beginning that process,
perhaps a good place to start
would be the Kundalini University.
(all laughs)
All of a sudden-
I was up for a plug.
All of a sudden, man, you just-
I'm going to stick the landing.
You just talk about it, talk about it,
good partnership here.
Yeah, we do teach,
we teach emotional wellbeing.
We teach mental wellbeing.
We teach physical wellbeing through the science of,
the ancient science of Kundalini yoga and meditation.
And also through other things too, the spiritual world,
the emotional world, the mental world,
the physical world at Kundalini University.com.
And it's not the only school.
I'm not even gonna say to anybody out there
that it's the best school, but it's my school.
So it's the school that I'm gonna promote,
but I'm not gonna try to promote it
by putting anything else down.
It has an opportunity.
And and if you look us up,
you'll see that there's so many ways
in which you can engage us.
Whether it's as simple, the simple freedom
of a daily reminder or the larger investment
of of a 16-week, 200-hour course.
I love the daily emails.
Sometimes I'm like, another one of these.
I don't have time to read this.
I know, and people have told me that.
And it doesn't hurt my feelings whatsoever,
But just the fact that it's there-
I go another one oof these, I don't have time to write it.
I'm in a bad mood, delete,
like I just can't do it today.
I love it-
You know but the next day there it is,
just it's always showing up no matter what.
Isn't that the beauty?
The beauty of the digital age
is really more important than the negativity
of the digital age, because it is so consistent.
It doesn't have an emotional let down.
It always shows up.
Relentless.
Relentlessly.
Well, always a treat and a pleasure
to talk to you, my friend.
Thank you for gracing us with your presence.
We'll do it again sometime soon, soon.
We'll do it again soon.
And until then-
Peace.
Plus.
Gratitude.
And take us out with a song.
Yeah.
You'll do that again?
I'd love to.
Cool.
Look at Jason.
He's all fired up to be a music tech.
Yeah.
Guitar tech.
It's so good.
Oh, you know, some great friends of mine,
every Kundalini class ends with this.
Some great friends of mine and the Incredible String Band
way back in the 1960s,
wrote a round, a song in the round, you know,
and (guitar buzzing) the refrain to it was,
♪ May the long time sun ♪
♪ Shine down upon you ♪
♪ Oh everlasting love and joy surround you ♪
♪ And the pure light ♪
♪ The pure light within you ♪
♪ Guide your way on ♪
(dramatic music)